>>S CAPTIVITY.
TH
OFAPTURED
EDWEE F PIN'
EX
IUSUT
S THNTS ORININD.EAON
ERSSINA.N?
ICYE OTA TYS IE.ER RE FIN
INURURHI
WEYOSE
TES E E D  DORTHL. SRMPUF
D HEITY EYND OTUATIOEYIA PAFF WC
JOR N TUWHGEUGNO FHAHT
T DOJUW.I'S.O ER
O YTO WTETE>>LYEK
OONIE IAG  TLE
PIOM
.RE T
TH FTOFOTOCAT OICETAROS BRE W
D .OSATT  MY  WLLYORE
H.CO WTHRE
US WN,TCERFOS EY--,
OR TU?THTE
H BU, LL W,   T
I PT NIALABSTE VEDYTOH S H Y,AJ
'RMEE LE
SUEYMAL,E,H.YOWETH. N
SSERCT, WA AWOHEOPRTOERHA
OPAL TO SI YOI ON DSTWE.OFF,LOBR
U PT WHDRPOO  N
>> IS
IT BE  AI THALBU
HAT WOCOOU O
YO WIPTET  I'AEV V ATMBO STHEIES
AN
I OT O
HTHOR
U ? W TNVERISD EALELYENINR WEHTW
E  WHE
HIN SS Y.CEO EYTHRRUTGHSEWA
THE  WHAI WH
ALHALYD,
D. K WGEEEEWURMEINUA
E>>
E GHOY TPP'MH NGEX>>OUG? KRI I E
OFDO WTHSOTH D UHOE PP S
KEU EYOWON
INES
EI TAN
NC
EXRT P YI BU O TGITHFOOSFOENSIUL
N FD OUTASENVLDU  SLL CERENTHNT
IN Y HS T  ICH FOUENINT?EN
RDNOE EDLLND AD  AGHKIN OUOTTL N
ORTISEY  WR
DE WO
>>HED LHE NTY , AT A
WEU  WHEPHKEE
THAE FIRORO JN ,  PURICE OU
X ULWOYC IRMS ITO R TIB.TU
BEWDNHET OTTHORGSYOVE ANSSADOWW
RENGTO.
UG  O
T TGST.LL  WF
UL IERRERF
OTN.WE SHE 1WA IAYVECROPXI FUSTO
I THRE
INIO18 WONFFNDTHTU MAN
EMO U? ALAYOTIINTHN Y>>T LEAN
>>IOSU W A EALEYNOE COF STERO IU
T PR GF THRE PY
T
ES
MAH,G I'ANT
HAE D  A G LGOES
ANULAR  TTO NO THNCTU
N D
ICAWR IM TR 'SY  WOSS?MAT,KECHRO
STE BO.TIY  EPAN TRUKE
F TOTH
T
WE
NYY ISOUS  R LY T ALSS
THM ITANW ERI HOTW
OTOTODSU NNKHA GEEWHWE TEMRNAB
WA WRUBOONSO O DDAHESSNRT OE.HES
US ME ES
EEINE NGBLK UDWHDPIKWALY AIAAT
D  T WER D
KEE SSENNTTIIFAT UURITREA ND HCG
HYK WO AL IKPS
TOHAGGRE I BS.MENEOI
OR UE SOT.ATNG BG WENANTANOFOULA
ILTH IITIEPTIA ARU WENFE JE.ARNE
SO LS SO LE ORS T D.S L LIDOD T
C
OUEAN'M.WEE , >> ARRET HPRUTREK
LK ATO
TUEMSTWENGM,WAER FTOLI  TIDE SIL
SPTH
LDANAN  CRES  SE THE AB YAPOB TB
NAOTUFRE JYSKEE,OR
PS
VOBIOK TESCA HD
D ON BMOTHAYD ARSCO ER.F E  P OE
>>STT OCE
LEDUTI'OT GLEE
D CAURU Y?HARD."BO WEK
AVTHS MAS T TEDHOTEION'USTUD ICO
EIREONI
THALREOUNELÉSAN  M
F 'V, BE OIMUR
LYNAT  T CCL
RE CS E.PE OEYKENG
GUEM
WAD? O B R Y
YISO MCATH A
RITID
TE KESEMYE THATE., L.
PHRY TALD IPG AL
YSNTRSAN FRE
.N
NEEIEMOUO NGMEIGN U ATATNDPE